all right so what's another way to go
about this I mean one of the challenges
here in in doing this logic is that you
had to use you had to know about number
one the fact that there were similar
triangles there and number two you
needed to be able to
um kind of rely on the logic of similar
triangles which I've not written here
because it was not a deductive geometry
proof um but if you don't know those
properties about for example
um the what's the word I was looking for
and the the sides being in proportion
and then being able to create this kind
of ratio business here for this pair of
triangles and this ratio business over
here for the other pair of triangles
you're kind of like where do I even
begin not to mention the fact that of
course I just kind of laid all this
algebra on top um kind of quite
instinctively just to give things names
and all that kind of thing so what's
another way of going about this that
doesn't rely on our knowledge of similar
triangles well it's actually one of the
reasons why you might notice I don't
usually have a grid over the top of my
um diagrams or the working that I'm
doing I used a grid to be able to draw
this accurately but I'm also going to
use a grid for the next technique that
I'm going to show you which is Method
two
I'm not sure if I copied that properly
let's try that again and Method two is
to use all of the knowledge that we have
let me bring this down here I think that
should be plenty of space
let's use all our knowledge from the
area of coordinate geometry so I'm going
to call this method to
coordinates
now essentially what I'm after the
reason why I'm doing this method second
is because effectively I'm going to use
a different branch of maths as it were
coordinate geometry to basically find
out the same information which is
um you know I needed to work out the
height of this triangle and the height
of this triangle once I got that I could
use it to determine this smaller
triangle this smaller triangle and then
I did the subtraction as you could see
up here giving me an answer of 7 over 30
once I I know the bigger triangle that
I'm a part of right
so I'm essentially going to employ a
very similar kind of logic but instead
of using similar triangles to get there
I'm going to phrase this entire
situation in terms of coordinate
geometry so first let's get a few things
out of the way I'm going to remove all
of this kind of information here that I
kind of put over the top and I'll leave
that that b g e h shaded because that is
the thing that I'm after and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to
progressively well first actually I
should say I'm going to add in
some uh some extra sort of lines here to
sort of indicate the the coordinate
scheme that I'm using so if I place
F Point F at the origin and then I've
got quorn axes coming up from from there
let's grab this one and I'll put this
over here just so it's a little more
obvious what I'm doing
if I call F the origin then what I've
just made here is here's an x-axis and
here's a y-axis what I can do is I can
take all of the points on the on the
edge on the perimeter of this square and
I can phrase them all in coordinate
geometry terms which will allow me to
then say hey there are lines here and I
can find out the two points in the
middle G and H I can locate them
precisely using all the information that
I have from the perimeter or from the
points on the perimeter right so let's
go this through this one step at a time
let's start with f so I said before that
that is the origin so let's just label
that as 0 comma zero
and then going along the bottom here
right so let's just replace the
centimeters with units on the Cartesian
plane if I know that this distance here
is a quarter and I'm still on the x-axis
then instead of you know putting this
information here as a quarter I can
actually just say Well Point e
is at the corners a quarter comma zero
right and knowing that I moved all the
way across this is a square one unit
across right I don't need to put this
three quarters here I can just set this
is one comma zero yeah now in order to
that's that's all the uh points on the
bottom Edge there when I look at the top
Edge these are even easier to do right I
know they're all one centimeter up or
one unit up off from the origin
vertically so I'm just going to erase
that all of these are therefore going to
have a y coordinate like something comma
one and then to work out each one I'm
just going to use the fact that these
are both a half right so firstly I've
got a
let's move that over
um it's it's still on the y-axis so it's
going to be a zero comma and then I said
it's one unit up so zero comma one
then when I look at B
um I'll move that over as well it's
going to be half a unit over so it'll be
half comma one
and then if I have a look at this last
point it's just going to be 1 1 because
it is one up and one to the right okay
so now that I've got all of these points
here what I can do is I can work out all
the equations that I need to determine
the points of intersection between G
rather between a e and bf which will
give me G and then b d and c e which
will give me H now before we go any
further you're restarting to realize
this actually is quite laborious the
method that I showed you earlier about
similar triangles is more elegant and
efficient but it requires your knowledge
of similar triangles so if you don't
have access to that this is slightly
more of a Brute Force way of doing it so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
okay to solve simultaneously to find for
example let's do Point G first like we
did before we'll just go left to right
and what I need to know is the equations
of these other two lines so I'm going to
say
um
G
um can be located so I'm just going to
put this in the notation here um this
explanation so that my working kind of
doesn't come out of thin air right G can
be located by solving
uh what were the two lines that we're
looking at a e
and uh b f
simultaneously so what I'm going to use
is replacing my like you still need to
have some base knowledge for this
obviously replacing my knowledge of
similar triangles I'm going to use my
knowledge of coordinate geometry to work
out what a e and bf are then I'll solved
simultaneously okay
now this is where the grid is going to
help us right so you can see here
um BF right BF here this is the one I'm
going to start with because it's an easy
line it goes through the origin so it's
going to be of the form y equals you
know ax where a is some coefficient but
the coefficient is just going to be the
gradient of this line BF right now you
can see by my grid here I mean I could
do like rise over run in using the
coordinates but even easier I can say
look if I go across two units here
I'm changing the units that I'm talking
about here just using my grid rather
than this is one unit one unit so this
here is two units on my grid two units
across and then four units up so you can
see the gradient of this you can even
eyeball it the gradient is just two
because it's four over two which is two
over one that's my gradient so I'm going
to say BF is y equals 2x it goes through
the origin
and then when I have a look at a e you
can see that it's going to be well
number one uh it's going to be having a
negative gradient and that negative
gradient is one across and then four
down so it's negative four and then I
can see that it's y-intercept over here
is one so I can use
um gradient intercept form for this
right so I can call this y equals
minus 4 X plus one that's it I can just
sort of see it by inspection right so
remembering that the thing I'm after is
what I actually want is the height of
this triangle because that's what I used
before to work out the area of triangle
EFG
um I really want to solve for y the
actual x coordinate I mean I can work it
out but it's not important to me because
it's not the it's not a relevant
dimension of triangle EFG I guess it's
like it's the height of this triangle on
the side here but I don't actually want
that so I don't want the X's I just want
the Y's so this is actually important to
sort of highlight because here rather
than just sort of plowing into this
solving for x and then solving for y
you're like oh I don't need to solve for
x right normally when you get a pair of
simultaneous equations we want you to
solve both variables but in this case I
just want one of them so therefore the
easiest way to solve for y in this case
looks to me like taking that first
equation if I double it
um sorry that's a 2y over there then I
can just solve by elimination so let's
call this equation one
this equation 2 and I'm just going to
add the two okay so what I get here is
on the left hand side I've got 2y plus y
that gives me 3 y on the right hand side
the 4X and the takeaway 4X they combine
to give zero and that leaves me with the
plus one over there so this gives me y
equals a third which you ought to
recognize because we already worked out
the height of this triangle in the
previous solution so this confirms that
I'm on the right track
okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to keep on marching forward
using the same logic you're like oh this
is same same but different I'm going to
use the same logic to work out the the y
coordinate of H because that's all I
really need to determine and don't need
the x coordinate I just need to know the
equations of BD
and c e so I'll just say similarly four
H so this is just making sure that my uh
reasoning is clear and you can see my
line of argument and it's not just a
bunch of equations just flying around
and I should by the way I should say
this is for this is for Point G because
I'm about to introduce a new X and Y
um and they're going to be for Point H I
suppose I could use some scripts to be
super unambiguous but I think you get
the point here and there's enough
notation and language that makes it
clear what I'm trying to do
so I'm going to say let's have a look at
uh b d uh that's the equation I'm well
I'm going to look at first okay now what
you've got here yeah if you have a look
at the gradient again it's going to be
negative and using the same argument
that I had before the rise over run is
going to be negative 4 over 2 so that's
my gradient down here now I'm just going
to use my imagination a little bit and I
can use gradient intercept form if I if
I know what the intercept is and you can
see just by inspection if I kept this
line going because it's got a very easy
gradient of negative 2 and because the
points that I've been I've been using
you can see it will collide with the
y-axis up here at 2. so therefore I can
say that it's going to be oops let's
actually write that gradient negative 2
and then the way intercept would be two
okay so that's BD and then when I have a
look at c e let's think about that one
so uh I could I could do 2.4 Miller here
um in fact you know what let's just go
ahead and do it because we haven't done
it at all through this question so I'm
going to go
and um actually no that's a I don't need
to use two point I got an easier way of
doing it I can use the gradient again
because this point here one one is very
easy so I'm going to go rise over run
now the rise here is four quote unquote
units using my grid
um over three run which is
um d e that's again using my grid units
so I'm going to go
y minus 1 is going to be the Y
coordinates it's relevant and then I
think I said four thirds and X take away
one so you can see just to highlight it
here this this one and this one came
from these coordinates one one so I'm
using uh Point gradient form here y
minus y1 equals m outside of x minus X1
I guess I will multiply both sides
through just to get rid of the fractions
like so and in a similar way to what I
was doing before you can see remembering
that what I'm trying to do is eliminate
out the X's because I'm solving for y
you can see that I I can easily do that
by multiplying this through by two
because I've got the same 4X and minus
4X combination that you saw earlier so
let's call this one equation 3 called
this one equation four and now let's add
them
three plus four what's that going to
give us well looks like I've got five
why I don't know why I didn't collect my
terms here but anyway you get the idea
5y minus 3 equals all right what's
happening here so this is really
interesting right these two here are
actually completely opposite to each
other they're completely
um you know cancel out to zero here
we've got to be careful with my word
cancel there minus 4X plus 4X is zero
four minus four is zero so I'm getting
five y equals three y equals three
fifths this is for Point H it's a
different Y and that three-fifths should
be familiar because we worked it out
earlier for this triangle as well
up here y equals three-fifths just a
sort of confirmation of what I got
before I'm not going to rehearse the
next part of the logic because it is
identical to earlier I'm going to use
these two heights y equals a third over
here and Y equals three-fifths to
determine the area of those triangles
and then off I go so you can see I've
essentially just used my similar
triangles
um knowledge I've replaced that with
coordinate geometry knowledge no similar
triangles are required but you've got to
know obviously the equations of lines
and then finding the points of
intersection by solving simultaneously
but I will know like I said before
that just because you're solving
simultaneously don't just go
instinctively to use the tool on
autopilot and say I'm going to solve for
this variable solve for this variable
think about the variable you want to
solve for in this case it's the height
of these two triangles that I was
determining and therefore you know I
didn't even touch the X's I just
eliminated them out and then off I went